[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein grundrezept für
pfannkuchen aber nicht die ganz
traditionell die habe ich nämlich schon
auf einem kanal sondern die glutenfreien
ohne mehl genau das funktioniert nämlich
sehr gut man kann das ganze auch
wirklich sehr protein reich machen ich
mache jetzt hier das rezept mit
magerquark 2 1 erfolg wird milch aber
ihr könnt auch hier einfach eine etwas
weniger fette milch verwenden falls ihr
das ganze aus gesundheitlichen gründen
etwas fitness optimierter machen möchtet
mir geht es jetzt einfach nur darum euch
eine glutenfreie hövel pfannkuchen
alternative zu geben magst du
pfannkuchen wie sehr
wenn ich frag was wir morgen zu
frühstücken am wochenende kommt oft
banken wobei hier sagt schon oft
porridge oder das motto der es schon
auch gut gerne auf jeden fall ich denke
ich mache
ja bis dahin so sehr maxi pfannkuchen
bis zum horizont
weißt du hast nur horizont ist
davor wird sondern dass keine
echte produktplatzierung ascheberger
hosentasche aber jetzt warte mal der
horizont ist das was man hinten
sieht wenn man draußen ganz weit schaut
oder wie hättet ihr jetzt in hochform zu
beschreiben so irgendwie naja ich sage
ich mal kurz die zutaten ich verwende
dafür
420 gramm milch 70 gramm quark besitzen
magerquark jeweils einen halben
teelöffel salz und zucker 100 gramm
stärke das maisstärke und zwei esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl
ok ich wurde gerade sagen es ist ein
sehr einfaches rezept denn man verrührt
einfach alle zutaten klümpchen frei
miteinander
frühere brühlerin ein abo mit ist du
denn deine pfannkuchen am liebsten
somit ist die am liebsten
frisch
und jetzt sogar
hat die punkerin entdeckt die gibt es
noch nicht kein problem hier weiter mit
frischkäse nutella
leben ist nichts draus machen also
einfach alles schön klümpchen frei
verrühren
zack zack zack da nicht nachlassen und
ich kann jetzt hier schon mal der pfanne
erhitzen ich nehme jetzt einfach eine
eisen pfanne die schon gut eingebrannt
ist die verwende ich ja immer für dinge
die ich scharf anbraten wie fleisch oder
bratkartoffeln und die hat einfach jetzt
schon eine schöne patina schöne
beschichtung deswegen kann ich da auch
recht fett arm die pfannkuchen zu
bereiten
die müssen halt so heraushören
so und die pfanne erhitzt auf stufe vier
mit dem rad sensor
genau ganz wenig das reicht stoppen da
reicht auch nur ein ganz kleiner
spritzer wasser
kunst das muss noch erhitzen schatz hier
wird die pfanne mit dem perfekt frei
kratzen so erwärmt und zwar auf stufe
vier ich hab da stufen von 15 und stufe
1 ist zb wenn man butter schmelzen
möchte und das ganze eben nicht hoch
spritzen soll stufe 5 werse und steak
braten ganz scharf und stufe 4 ist
perfekt für pfannkuchen die werden schön
braun verbrennen aber nicht uns die
pfanne wird dann praktisch nur so heiß
bis zu einem bestimmten grad und
überhitzt nicht und wenn sie aber doch
wieder herunterkühlt weil man zum
beispiel was kaltes reinlegt dann jetzt
heißt es von allein wieder auf also sage
ich ganz praktisch
ich wollte es nur erklären wie man das
aufheizt ok darf ich das erste mal kurz
machen den ersten pankofen und du darfst
den nächsten okay okay an die hast ja
und wenn ihr kein perfekt frei habt
standen einfach auf mittel hohe hitze
und dann einfach die stufe immer ein
bisschen kontrollieren
pinke pfannkuchen nein nein nein keine
farbe
wir machen keine finke von und ich nehme
jetzt bei der pfanne einfach die größe
mal gucken ob es passt und wenn ihr
diesen perfekt frei samson ich habe dann
einfach auf mittel hohe hitze die
herdplatte erwärmen und die temperatur
einfach gucken dass er sie konstant
halten aber nicht so heiß
der sturm macht immer power boost und
dann geht immer alles ganz schnell aber
er brennt noch immer sehr schnell
kann so schütteln dann sieht man auch
schon ob der plan fertig ist
es den browser noch dann löst das ich
gleich besser da kann ich den in der
pfanne umdrehen verstehen zu hoch
schmeißen
darf sich schafft das
ok auf die da oben ok ich gebe mein
bestes
selbst machen auf die kamera
ich habe den jungs war faktor dazu
hast du auf dass du nicht runterfällt
[Musik]
solches programm
knipst sie
sofort ja
weil da zu viel fett in der pfanne waren
da hat jemand ganz viel vertrauen
gesprüht erwartet
[Musik]
hatte ich es nochmal wissen lassen da
nicht fertig und dann stapeln wir die
alle und probieren
[Musik]
ach ja
entschuldigung den nächsten tag schon
auf jeden fall machen okay
so und immer schön schwenken guck mal
kannst du das ganz schaffst du das doch
jetzt ist gleichmäßig verteilt jetzt mal
kurz warten und dann darfst du gleich
machen okay okay
mein versuch wert ja
gemeint so und dann noch ein bisschen
weniger sofas zu führen
und jetzt die pfanne schwenken
bisschen helfen
bisschen schwer
[Musik]
was ich helfe dir ich hab dir nochmal
zwischen zustand
[Musik]
jetzt will ich
mein hielt mit es werden jetzt zu viele
zutaten
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier die fanfaren
ausgebackenen turner kommen dazu ella
ist einfach verschwunden morath schätze
gesucht ja im ganzen haus hier und dort
und am grundstück oben und im garten
auf trampolinen sie ist nirgends naja
egal dann probieren wir oder war habe
ich jetzt hier einmal die glutenfreien
das sind nicht alle wir haben noch mehr
aber die sind schon bei sarah zum
fotografieren und hier habe ich noch
welche gemacht die sind vegan und das
rezept teile ich einfach mit euch da ich
mir gedacht das spar ich mir jetzt zu
zeigen weil es war halt einfach mail und
pflanzen milch und wasser da treibe ich
einfach das rezept auf dem blog dann
haben wir nämlich alles vollständig wir
haben dann normale pfannkuchen dann
trittin freie und vegan
kann man mit denen auch
pfannkuchen mit
sparen machen oh ja und da will hier ein
tipp von jörg diese eckige fange als ihr
habt ja auch gesehen ich aber in der
eisenbahn hat die ausgebacken eisen und
gusseisen ist perfekt zum pfannkuchen
auspacken und der jmd magie und macht
ecke pfannkuchen und dann kann man den
spargel eine richtig auf rolle
richtig
warum warum herunterfahren
daran habe stets gleichmäßig über alle
pfannkuchen weil die mich nervt immer
wenn man mit ihren pfannkuche rasch ein
spargel verstehen der mitte zu viel teig
und ausland
und hier habe ich eine pfanne die habe
ich neulich schon mit vom thema wieder
weg mit dem filzball einstimmig macht
also die stets frisch aber das gleiche
rezept sondern die damit probieren
denn ich glaube also ich mag dran kuchen
gerne herzhaft und als abschluss zum
süßen vorjahr mitten also ich als meine
mit nutella und dann noch diese stadt
modellen drauf
und nach zimt und zucker also alle alles
zusammen normalerweise noch abholen muss
drauf aber man weiß dass zu viel das ist
dann echt harbour
hotel und dann noch zum zug
so
hätte man vielleicht ein
ja
packen
wer jetzt gut wenn wir einmal vergleich
hat mit mir
gut der schaltwege aber ich finde es
auch normal ab ganz normal in franken
nur finde ich wenn mehr drin ist hat es
so bisschen eine andere konsistenz desto
lustiger also wirklich so feuchter
haben dann aber wenn man es nicht weiß
das aufräumen
ersten gang
bevor wir nichts mehr schmecken stimmt
da habe ich ein bisschen backpulver 1
das tape ist in luftiger
aber dann merkst du die kommunisten zu
lernen was mitnehmen
als er mein lieblingsrezept sind immer
noch normale pfannkuchen also standard
rezept basic rezept mit milch aber ich
muss sagen wenn man sie mag ihn frei und
mehl frei machen möchte auch vielleicht
lockt haben ein bisschen dann finde ich
die ganz gut die sind echt gut also auch
manchmal wäre es auch zu abenteuerlich
abendessen dann will ich oft kein brot
ist damit mir das einfach zu viel jetzt
hat weil ihre kalorien sparen will oder
so sondern mir wird das brot dann zu
viel so dass mail da drin und ich glaube
wenn ich dann so was erst wie so eine
pilzpfanne und dann zur pflanzung und
ohne mehl damit ein bisschen leichter
einfach
jetzt gibt's kein brot mehr
weil wir nicht morgens schon fortgesetzt
dann kann ich abends nicht noch mal das
macht so viel
aber die veganen sind auch gut schlagen
und danach dann einen mit
schokolade oder nougat vor wichtig weil
meine mama hat immer gemacht die
schwankungen und dann sonne pilzpfanne
dazu das war immer so unser unser
highlight
am liebsten löffeln alles nur
fehlt noch ein bisschen aber
dann
die rezepte findet ihr
alles - blog de oder in meiner app die
panne ist ein grundrezept das konzept
erst schön alles kombinierbar probiert
gerne mal aus und schreibt mir auch
gerne mal wie ihr die pfannkuchen am
liebsten es also herzhaft oder süß und
mit welchem belag
wenig auf dem weihnachtsmarkt bin dann
bin ich schon so
themenhotel ja aber musste gleich
was meine mama auch immer gemacht hat
war es im pfannkuchen und nur züge rein
und ich mag das wenn es so kommt
aber zu dem zucker ist noch mal besser
also ich kann man nochmal geschmack oder
frischkäse und marmelade oder bis frisch
mit frischkäse ist auch lecker morgens
selber ist mit frischkäse oder oliven so
dazu oder mit wörtern mit diesem
beispiel dann ist sowieso zuckerberg
naja
ok es eskaliert
bis zur nächsten wahl
das ist einfach so für gutes essen wenn
wir so viele kombination machen wenn du
denn wir wollen ja deswegen zeigen wir
so erstaunlich aber jetzt kommen noch
kombination von den zuschauern praktisch
füllung ist auch sehr sehr gut
ok
also
mit 14 schon mit eines probiert
[Musik]